fundada en 1949 como un país socialista
de línea dura la república popular de
china ha cambiado mucho desde entonces
tanto que si el mismísimo mao levantara
la cabeza probablemente se volvería a
caer del susto
[Música]
amigo si en los años 70 china no era más
que un país de agricultores muy pero que
muy pobres hoy es toda una superpotencia
ningún país en la historia ha crecido
tan rápido ni ha sacado a tantas
personas de la pobreza como ha hecho
china en los últimos 40 años durante
este tiempo este país ha crecido a un
ritmo promedio de casi el 10 por ciento
anual y lo más importante de todo casi
800 millones de personas más que toda la
población de américa latina españa y
portugal han escapado de la pobreza
[Música]
pero amigos creo que esto no es nuevo ni
para vosotros ni para nadie es algo que
de una forma u otra todos conocemos
ahora bien como logro chinas semejante
cambio pensáis que toda esta
transformación ha sido el resultado de
un plan minuciosamente trazado de una
estrategia cuidadosamente diseñada y
planificada por los líderes chinos pues
amigos creo que en toda esta historia
hay algo que os va a sorprender atentos
por cierto queremos agradeceros el gran
apoyo que nos estáis brindando en patrón
en apenas unos días habéis sido más de
500 los que os habéis sumado a esta
iniciativa estamos preparando muchas
sorpresas y con vuestra ayuda será mucho
más fácil
[Aplausos]
el día 1 de octubre de 1949 mao tse tung
proclamó desde la plaza de tiananmen en
pekín la república popular de china
y lo hizo expresando una consigna muy
clara china
se ha puesto en pie
[Música]
ah
y
sin embargo durante las siguientes tres
décadas la realidad fue muy diferente
mao fue algo así como un obseso de la
ideología un personaje dispuesto a
implantar el modelo de sociedad que
tenía en su cabeza a cualquier precio y
entre otras cosas amigos pensaba que
pekín podía decidir sobre todo y
determinar el futuro de todo
[Música]
cuanto a producir que producir cómo
repartir a los trabajadores cuántas
fábricas hacían falta cómo se
repartirían los bienes la producción
etcétera etcétera y no sólo eso la otra
cosa que mantenía muy pero que muy clara
era que cualquier disidencia era un
peligro que había que eliminar
[Música]
y claro como os podéis imaginar las
ideas en manos de alguien con tanto
poder y tanta obstinación tienen
consecuencias
algunos estudios atentos calculan que
durante los casi 30 años que mahou fue
el gran líder supremo de china entre 50
y 70 millones de personas perdieron la
vida como consecuencia de las hambrunas
las persecuciones políticas y la más
absoluta miseria entre 50 y 70 millones
de personas que salvajada si queréis en
un próximo vídeo podemos hablar de todas
las grandes ideas de máó bueno el caso
es que tras 30 años en el poder tras
colectivizar toda la tierra y todas las
propiedades de china y de perseguir
brutalmente con la revolución cultural a
millones y millones de intelectuales
académicos profesores y a cualquier
persona que no fuera cómoda para el
régimen china era un país sumido en la
más absoluta miseria
los primeros años de la revolución
cultural no sólo fueron un caos fueron
un caos salvajes frank dikotter
historiador de la universidad de hong
kong
y
en aquel momento más del 80% de los
chinos vivían en unas condiciones
miserables las hambrunas no eran
extrañas el terror político las purgas
estaba a la orden del día y el nivel de
vida amigos era comparable al de alguno
de los países más pobres del áfrica
subsahariana y todo ello mientras japón
y los dragones asiáticos hong kong
taiwán corea del sur y singapur ya
estaban despegando menudo éxito por eso
no puede extrañarnos que cuando mao
murió en 1976 el partido comunista chino
se dividiera en tres facciones muy
diferentes entre sí
los radicales liderados por bianchi la
mismísima viuda de mao los reformistas
moderados de juego font y los
reformistas más agresivos liderados por
deng xiaoping
al final tras muchos tiras y aflojas y
tras quedar claro que china no daba más
de sí en 1978 fueron estos últimos los
reformistas más convencidos los que se
llevaron el gato al agua
[Música]
el gato negro y el gato blanco recordáis
las preguntas que hacíamos al principio
pues vayamos con la primera cómo
diantres cambió el rumbo de china
en diciembre de 1978 en el décimo primer
congreso del partido comunista chino el
reformista deng xiaoping se hizo con el
liderazgo del país
den xiaoping defendía que había que
dejar a un lado toda esa utopía
ideológica que tanto daño había hecho a
china y que había que apostar
decididamente por la modernización de
hecho su frase más célebre seguro que la
conoces es esa que dice no importa que
el gato sea blanco o negro mientras
pueda cazar ratones es un buen gato team
shopping y amigos eso es precisamente lo
que hizo durante los siguientes 10 años
porque si algo tenemos que decir es que
las reformas rápidas lo que se dice
rápidas no fueron pero puede que os
estéis preguntando
vale vale pero alberto cuáles fueron
exactamente sus prioridades pues desde
el punto de vista económico podemos
clasificar las reformas en tres grandes
bloques la agricultura la industria y el
comercio el punto de partida fue el
campo ya hemos dicho que por aquel
entonces china era fundamentalmente un
país de campesinos
[Música]
pues bien con la reforma agraria sedes
colectivo el campo y se suprimieron las
comunas que fueron sustituidas por el
modelo de explotación familiar de toda
la vida
además se implantó el sistema de
responsabilidad familiar por el cual
muchas decisiones como qué tipos de
cultivos plantar qué inversiones hacer
qué herramientas qué aparejos comprar
pasaron del gobierno de los burócratas a
las propias familias y no sólo eso una
parte de la cosecha el campesino se la
vendía al estado pero el resto podía ser
vendida en los mercados libres a precios
completamente libres
y eso amigos fue toda una revolución
pero una revolución de las buenas claro
la producción agrícola se disparó y los
precios de los alimentos cayeron
mientras las condiciones de vida de los
campesinos mejoraron un montón
[Música]
y como los resultados fueron tan buenos
pues en pekín decidieron aplicar
reformas similares a la industria de
esta forma el gobierno trasladó poco a
poco la toma de decisiones desde los
ministerios de pekín a las propias
empresas públicas si seguían siendo
públicas pero digamos que empezaron a
funcionar con criterios diferentes
de esta forma poco a poco a lo largo de
los años 80 los directivos de las
empresas públicas fueron capaces de
tomar decisiones como por ejemplo
repartir los beneficios entre los
trabajadores pagar primas de
productividad tener libertad para
contratar y despedir a sus empleados
decidir con qué proveedores trabajar
fijar precios libres etcétera etcétera
tiene sentido no os parece bien mejor
que los propios responsables de las
empresas para saber que necesitan estas
para funcionar mejor
pues además todo ello fue acompañado de
la legalización de la empresa privada
así que de repente las empresas públicas
pasaron a tener competencia y por otro
lado estuvo también la reforma comercial
por la que poco a poco china fue
permitiendo el comercio exterior
desmontando en buena medida las trabas y
los aranceles que existían a las
importaciones sin embargo he esperado un
momento amigos porque más allá de la
agricultura las reformas se enfrentaron
a un problema descomunal china era un
país muy pobre y claro no tenían ni
capital ni tecnología así que qué
pensáis que hizo el gobierno atentos
[Música]
zonas económicas especiales
a principios de los años 80 china era un
país pobre cerrado al mundo y no tenía
ni dinero ni tecnología pero lo que sí
tenía era mucha mano de obra deseosa de
trabajar en mejores condiciones que las
que separaba el campo
así que dadas las circunstancias el
gobierno de deng xiaoping decidió hacer
un experimento como no querían todavía
renunciar completamente al modelo
económico heredado de máó pero tenían
que hacer algo se les ocurrió crear
zonas económicas especiales lugares
donde el sistema comunista dejaba de
funcionar
en estas zonas en estas áreas las
empresas extranjeras odian invertir y
montar fábricas es decir podían tener
acceso a la mano de obra china y eso de
por sí ya podría ser una gran ventaja
pero ahí no quedaba todo
además disfrutaban de pocos impuestos
relativamente poca burocracia y encima
no tenían aranceles
vamos que eran algo así como pequeños
oasis para las multinacionales en medio
de la entonces hermética y hostil
república popular de china
la idea de pekín era muy clara traer
tecnología capital y trabajo
inicialmente se montaron cuatro zonas
económicas especiales las de shenzhen
zhuhai xiamen y shantou y el éxito fue
tan grande que pronto las autoridades
empezaron a crearlas como zetas por todo
el país
ahí está por ejemplo el caso de shenzhen
cuando se creado esta zona económica
especial en este lugar
shenzhen no era más que un pueblo de
pescadores pobres donde apenas vivían
30.000 personas hoy en cambio tiene 12
millones de habitantes su pib va a
superar próximamente al de la mismísima
hong kong y es conocida por ser una de
las capitales mundiales de la tecnología
todo en apenas unas pocas décadas
[Música]
conocéis empresas como huawei de jotas o
tensión pues son precisamente de esta
ciudad el éxito de estas zonas
económicas fue tan grande que bien
podemos decir que fueron las precursoras
de la apertura china a la zona económica
especial de shenzhen es un experimento
necesitamos más tiempo para ver si ha
ido bien le deseamos éxito pero si falla
brindará elecciones importantes den
xiaoping porque amigos inicialmente la
idea de deng xiaoping era utilizar estas
zonas no para abrir el país sino para
que el gobierno lograra recursos con los
que mantener el viejo modelo y es que se
suele pensar que la gran transformación
de china fue perfectamente trazada
diseñada y calculada por el gobierno de
pekín sin embargo y creo que esto puede
que os sorprenda no fue del todo así
atentos
la revolución marginalista
pensamos que las reformas chinas fueron
planificadas por el gobierno de pekín
pero un momento realmente fue así
pues veréis tras la muerte de mao china
era un país que estaba destrozado la
última cruzada del llamado gran timonel
la revolución cultural había dejado al
país exhausto
la ironía de la revolución cultural es
que hacia 1971 la mayoría de la gente al
menos en el campo había perdido la fe en
el comunismo frank dikotter historiador
de la universidad de hong kong de hecho
fue durante este periodo cuando
empezaron a extenderse los mercados
negros lugares donde al margen del
sistema la gente trataba de sobrevivir y
eso supuso también un cambio cultural
muy importante tal vez por eso tras la
muerte de mao ante el caos de la
transición algunos cambios empezaron a
producirse de forma automática por
ejemplo mientras el gobierno seguía
impulsando la agricultura colectivizada
en algunas regiones se rebelaron y
decidieron poner en marcha por su cuenta
el sistema de explotación familiar
incluso aunque eso suponía violar las
leyes y regresar de facto a un sistema
de explotación privada
y como de repente la iniciativa sumó a
más y más adeptos el gobierno de pekín
al final decidió establecer estos
cambios como política estatal pero
realmente fue un seguidor de los cambios
que se habían producido ya en la
sociedad algo parecido ocurrió también
con los negocios privados en las
ciudades
[Música]
tras la muerte de mao tse tung muchos
jóvenes que habían sido enviados al
campo regresaron a las ciudades y como
no había trabajo se lo buscaron por su
cuenta y el gobierno simplemente lo tuvo
que aceptar y así es como de repente las
tiendas privadas empezaron a surgir como
setas en las ciudades de china
terminando de esta forma de una vez y
para siempre con el monopolio comercial
del estado
[Música]
y en cierto modo también ocurrió lo
mismo con las empresas municipales y
regionales que empezaron a surgir fuera
del control del estado gracias a lo cual
durante años fueron las más dinámicas de
toda china sí es verdad el gobierno de
deng xiaoping no frenó estos cambios
todo lo contrario los acabo asumiendo
como política pero como veis gran parte
del cambio lejos de lo que se nos cuenta
vino de abajo hacia arriba y no de
arriba hacia abajo tal vez por eso la
transformación de china ha sido tan
grande en tan poco tiempo por cierto
antes de que nos deis de palos den
xiaoping no fue un santo fue un dictador
con todas las letras como el resto de
líderes chinos sin ir más lejos la
represión de tienanmen fue
responsabilidad suya
pero ahora turno para ti crees que china
terminará convirtiéndose en una
democracia déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
dale al like y compártelo con tus amigos
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]